Now that we've talked about remote control
preset and how that works, we're going to actually add
another layer of control to our scene.
And I'm going to show you some concepts that will actually
work with our scene and given us
full control for our materials.
That concept is called Material Parameter Collections.
So let's go ahead and go to Unreal and take a look at that.
In this generic scene, now this one I'm not giving you,
but I'm going to show you how this works so you can
understand the concept and how the strength of working
with a Material Parameter Collection.
In this scene, we have a Material Parameter Collection
already set up in each one of these objects.
You'll see that there's rain actually activated
in the background, but it's not visible at this time.
And the reason why is because the material is set
within a sequence and we can activate it.
So you can actually control your Material Parameter
Collections in a sequence if you needed,
or you can also control it on a functional level
when you're building your scene,
which is kind of what we're going to do.
So how this works is in your scene,
and I'm going to go to my cinematics here for a moment,
and I'm going to go to my MPC simple animation.
And if I drag across, you'll see that slowly
the rain turns on and things get a lot more wet.
And that's the power, one of the many things
you can do when it comes to
Material Parameter Collections.
You can actually have things change over time
via a sequence, or you can simply construct
and make and change variables
within an object in the material,
which we're going to focus on.
Off to the left, you'll see the parameters available
and exposed within Sequencer.
Now we're not going to get into this too much here,
how to do this in Sequencer,
because we have other classes that talk about this,
but I'm going to show you how to actually set up
a Material Parameter Collection in a ICVFX scenario
when you're working and editing things
and getting them ready to go to the LED volume.
But I'm going to tear back
some of those layers for a second.
I'm going to talk about some of those concepts
in this scene for a moment,
and then we're going to go to our LED volume scene
that we're going to be using.
I'm going to select this rock in this scene here.
I'm going to take a closer look at its material.
If I go to its details here,
we'll see that there is a rock material,
and I'm going to double click on this.
In this rock material,
you will see that I have a Material Parameter Collection.
Now these are nodes that hold information,
and I'm going to hit Control and Wheel Mouse
a little bit closer here.
These nodes, if I double click on it,
will allow me to expose parameters
that I need for my scene.
And in this particular case, all of it is scalar.
And what I mean by scalar is basically
a range that we can control.
We have a global roughness high,
we have a global roughness low,
and we have a global, we have a wetness intensity,
and we also have a water material opacity.
And all those things we're using
to make that water show up on the scene.
And again, we won't be using water in that case,
but I'm going to show you how to build
this Material Parameter Collection,
and we're going to associate it with a color information
as well as being able to control our saturation.
So let me go ahead and close this.
We're not going to save.
And I'm going to close this scene.
And we'll go back to the one that we already have.
And we're going to build that out.
So I have a little sample here, a little backup samples
that we can give available for you.
This is just a quick test that you can also populate
and build your own different types
of Material Parameter Collections.
And I'm just going to keep going
with that vein of thought.
We're going to go ahead and build this out.
But let's actually go to the slides
because I want to point something out to you
in our lecture on how this works.
First, we're going to talk about
the overview of the concept.
We're going to set it up
and then we're also going to create the blueprint
for control.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the concept overall.
Now here's some of the things that you can control.
And I want to point this out because
even though you saw me play with like the water material
or actually have a material have more specularity,
there's so much more you can do.
And there's so many layers.
And I'm going to make sure I take the time
to point this out
because it's very important to consider.
You can control your caustics for fog effects.
You can adjust rock specular roughness,
which you saw me do.
You can also control albedo height blend effects
if you needed to.
So you can actually make it so like,
hey, I want to increase my moss or my snow on an object.
All those things are available there
when you plug these in in the right area.
And then again, we can connect it as you can see here,
we can connect it to our remote control preset.
So what we're going to do now is build this material.
I'm going to walk you step-by-step
how to build this material.
And then we're going to create a blueprint
in which we can link this material to it.
So let's go ahead and go back into Unreal
and see how that is done.
So in Unreal here, let's go ahead
and make a few things here.
You'll see that I have a blueprint.
This is one of the things we're going to need.
We have a material that we want to use,
our object of interest here.
And we have an MPC test.
Now your material can be anything.
You just have to decide ahead of time exactly
what kind of material you want,
what are your goals
and how you want to break things down.
We're going to keep our material in this particular case
very simple.
We're not going to get too complex with it.
So for those of you that may be rusty at materials,
you should be able to follow along just fine.
I'm going to right click here.
And what I'm going to do is go to materials
and there you go, almost lost.
Where is that?
I'm going to go to materials.
I'm going to go to a material parameter collection.
I'm going to click on this
and we'll call this MPC underscore new.
So I'm connected to source control.
It's waiting for that information.
I'm not going to bother.
I'm going to eventually rip these out,
but always keep in mind what you're adding
and how you're adding
and make sure you put it in there in the right order.
So we have an MPC new.
We also want to create a new material.
So I'm going to right click here.
I'm going to go to materials
and I'm going to create a material.
And again, you can quickly just go up here
to materials at the top.
And here I'll call this M underscore new.
We also want to be able to go in here
and make sure we have a blueprint
and we'll do that later.
We're not going to do that just yet.
So let's go ahead and double click on this material.
We're going to call this one up.
And what we're going to do is make a material
for this particular rock here on the left.
So let's go and find the textures
that are associated with this rock.
I'll click on it
and we'll go to the generic material that I made earlier.
And I'm going to open that generic material up temporarily
and we're going to grab these textures here.
Now, obviously they can be any texture that you want.
I'm just going to be kind of a little bit of a thief
and grab my one that I already pre-existed.
And you can go in the files that we give you.
It's any of the mega scans
and grab whatever that you need for whatever object.
Just make sure the UVs are lined up correctly.
So I'm just going to control C,
grab those, grab that information,
move this out of the way
so I don't mix up my workflow on what's what,
because I have a couple of materials open
and I'm going to paste this right here.
There we go.
I'm going to go full screen for a second,
just so you can follow along a little bit better.
I'm going to pull my materials in order.
So we have a texture sample,
we have a texture normals,
and then we just have an erroneous texture
that if you want to pull in and use this for roughness,
I'm going to leave it kind of out of here for now.
I didn't really use it in my sample,
so I won't really use it here.
And if I wanted to,
if those values are in there that I need,
I can pull from the green or the blue,
whatever I want to represent my roughness.
But in this case,
we're going to keep that pretty steady, pretty simple.
So now we need to actually go in here and look,
let me go and shrink this down just for a second.
We need to actually look at our MPC that we made,
the new one,
and we need to actually create a couple of things.
We need to create a scalar parameter
and a vector parameter
that we can actually access and open up.
So I'm going to double click on this.
I'm going to open this up
and you'll see like the interface is a little bit different
than what you may be used to
if you've never used this before.
It's pretty straightforward.
There's a scalar section and there's a vector section,
an area for color information
and an area for ranges
that you want to be able to adjust sliders
or a number information
and make it so that you can control the amount.
So the scalar one,
we want to hit a plus here, pop that up.
This scalar is going to be
the amount of intensity that we want.
So we can call this tint.
We'll say new,
so we don't mix up with any of our other MPCs,
new underscore tint intensity.
And we'll go over here and hit another plus.
This will be in our color area.
Oh, I accidentally hit it twice.
Anytime you do that,
or you have one that you don't want,
you can actually hit delete.
You do got to be careful.
It's kind of over sweeping when you hit delete,
kind of cleans out everything.
So if you do mess up,
just make note of it.
I'm going to hit a plus here.
I'm going to open up this little arrow
and in here,
I'm going to go ahead and give it a name.
This is going to be our new underscore color.
Again, you can associate to the object,
call it color rock.
I'm just going to keep it new
so I can keep track of what I need to get rid of later
for lecture purposes.
All right.
So now that I have that all set in,
you can hit save to save that one.
And we're going to go back
into the new material that we made.
So with that MPC in place,
I can now,
let me close my stats
cause it's eating up some of my real estate.
I can go now,
grab my MPC that I created,
my new MPC and drag that into my scene.
And we're going to actually talk about connecting this
and making the association correct in just a second.
So what we want to do now is while I'm in this scene,
I'm going to actually do a little bit of blending.
So we have an MPC here.
This particular MPC needs to know what parameter name
it's accessing in that MPC.
So what that means is we made a scalar parameter
and made a color vector parameter.
So we need to know and let Unreal know
exactly which one we are accessing
for this particular function and process that we want to do.
So in this one, I want to choose my color.
I'm going to duplicate this MPC control D,
bring this one down and this one I want to be my tint.
So I'm going to change that to new in tint intensity.
There you go.
So now these both have association
and because the parameters are open in there,
it's now going to go to the one that I've designated.
So let's do a quick, simple blending method here.
I'm going to grab my color information.
I'm going to grab my color texture of my rock
and I'm going to grab my new color MPC
and I'm going to use a blending in here.
Now again, you can do this any way that you want.
Just make sure that it makes sense for what you're doing.
I'm going to do a thing called blend overlay.
This blend overlay will just make it
so I can have the color right on top of things.
And I'm going to grab this MPC new color,
plug it into blend and I'm going to grab my base RGB.
This is very logical here.
Pull that into the base and there we go.
I'm going to actually pull in my intensity here for MPC
and I'm going to pull it into the alpha of alert.
So I'm going to get my finger on the L key
and do my linear interpret node.
And again, the linear interpret node, if you've forgotten,
allows us to do like a nice 50-50 blend
between our two different objects that we're plugging in.
So I'm going to pull in my blend overlay
into the A channel.
Actually, excuse me.
I did that a little bit backwards here.
I want to get my red color information, sorry about that,
into my base of my blending.
And I'm going to grab my true RGB, the actual color,
into A because we want to be able to mask
this color changes on top of our RGB
so it has to go into the A channel.
That's a reason why I'm using kind of the blend overlay
so I can just bring them in together.
And I'm just pulling some of the simple texture data
from the red channel into that base here.
And it actually should work just fine.
I'm going to grab that result
and put it into the B channel here.
From there, I'm going to grab my new tint intensity
and pull it into the alpha.
From there, I'm going to pull the final execution string
into my base.
And I'm going to keep this pretty simple.
I'm going to leave the default spec
and some of these defaults roughness.
I'm not worried about that right now.
I just want to show you the control that you get
with remote control.
And I'm going to grab the RGB for my normal
and just plug that into the normal.
And we should be good to go with that.
All right, so I'm now going to hit apply.
It's going to apply that material information
and the changes that we made.
That has my two MPCs.
It really is just one that's been altered
based on the channels that I've chosen
in the parameter name.
And it knows exactly what I'm going for.
So all that's all lined up and ready to go.
So now if I want to, I can grab my new material
and I can drag that material to my cliffs.
There we go.
But we don't have control of this just yet.
We do generically, if we just went into the material
and messed and fudged with the MPCs,
but we don't want to do that.
We want to have it so that we have a blueprint
in our scene that we can use and tweak
and connect to our remote control preset.
And I'm going to show you that on a generic level.
And towards the end of this class, in another video,
I'm going to show you how to do this via the iPad,
which we're going to get everything all moving
and allowing us to be able to remote control stuff.
All right, so let me go and move this out of the way
temporarily.
What we're going to do now is create a new blueprint.
So I'm going to go and right click here.
I'm going to go to blueprint class.
I'm going to choose actor.
And again, actor is the most diversified one
that I can choose.
And this one allows me to do pretty much anything
if I need to,
and allows me to be able to connect
to all sorts of different options.
We're going to choose actor
because we're going to use this for a material purpose.
So I'm going to click on actor here.
I'm going to click on BP blueprint,
and I'm just going to say underscore.
Oh, looks like it's auto saved right on top of me
trying to rename it.
Try that again.
BP underscore new.
There we go.
All right, so I'm going to now double click
on this blueprint.
Let me go and drag this blueprint over.
It went and showed up on another screen.
And I'll open this up.
So what we're going to do now
is we're going to start creating our blueprint
so that we can get this blueprint
to talk to this material.
Then we're going to drag this blueprint into our scene,
and we should be able to open up our parameters
and be able to have everything talk to each other
the way that we intend.
One of the first things we're going to want to do
is go to our event graph.
And let me open this up so you can see this a bit better
In my event graph,
I'm going to delete all these nodes that I don't need.
I don't need the event tick,
don't need the event begin overlap or event begin play.
None of those are going to fit our purposes
of what we want to do.
What I want to do is go in here
and create a thing called a custom event.
I'm going to do custom event.
And we're going to do add custom event.
I'm going to call this new underscore update MPC.
And I'm going to leave this here
because now what we need to do
is we need to actually,
if you're familiar with blueprints,
we need to actually have it
so we have an active functionality
working with a type of construction concept.
When you're working with the construction script,
you can change form and shape
and you'll do that within the editor.
But that doesn't mean it's going to show up on the wall
or show up on different areas,
say as you're projecting or sharing this file.
In some way, like in game mode, it won't show up.
We're focused on the LEDs.
So that's our concept here.
And we want to be able to have this construction script
update on the fly and talk to our event graph
at the same time.
So that node that I created new update MPC
is now going to have to go into my construction script
to bridge the gap between one,
which is used for construction
and the other one, which is used for real-time updates.
So I'm pulling this node in here
and I'm now going to drag this string
from my construction script into my new update MPC.
So now that we have that, I'm going to hit compile.
There we go.
We don't have any errors, so it's successful.
You'll see that underneath your compiler results.
And we're going to go back to our event graph.
Now that we've kind of linked that,
we now actually need to create a couple of things
called set parameter information.
So we're going to right click the first one here.
I'm going to type in set scalar,
because we've created a scalar parameter value.
There it is, boop, right there.
And it makes that noise sometimes.
I'm going to pull a string right here,
pull it right to set scalar parameter value.
And then with this set scalar parameter value,
Unreal's very smart.
It will know what our intentions are
because it knows that that's a scalar
and it'll only pick once I set the right MPC in place,
which is our new one,
it will only allow me to access anything that's scalar
and only have one thing.
So that makes it pretty simple.
I'm just going to get new tint intensity.
Now to be able to activate this,
we need to actually go in here
and go ahead and promote this variable right here.
I'm going to right click it.
I'm going to promote that to a variable,
that node here.
And this float has now been promoted.
And now this float is going to allow us
to be able to have this information digested correctly.
I'm going to change the name of this
to new underscore tint.
If I can type underscore amount.
Bam, all ready to go.
So with that set in place,
I need to now make another one that accesses the color.
And that's going to be a vector.
So I'm going to right click,
or I can pull the string and just type.
Unreal has my content sensitive in here.
So I'm going to type in set vector parameter value.
Pull that up.
Do the same thing we just did.
Go to my collections, go back down to my new MPC.
Got to do my parameter name.
I want to know what's in that MPC that I need.
My new color.
And then this one right here,
we're going to promote this guy.
Promote to a variable.
This is my linear color information.
You'll see the variable type right here.
We need to change its name
and we'll call it new color.
And you can call it color control if you want to.
It's really just activating these
and letting Unreal know in our blueprint
what our intentions are.
Now there's a step I missed here.
We need to actually consider.
So we need to go in here
and click on each one of these variables
and we need to make it instance editable.
Click on this instance editable.
That makes it so it updates
and it makes it so that we can edit this on the fly.
Not done though,
because we need to go into the update MPC
and we need this MPC to talk this node,
this custom event to talk to my editor.
So we're going to click on call in editor right there.
And we're going to hit compile.
So now that this blueprint is active
and doing what we want,
I'm going to move over here.
And now that that's compiled
and for the heck of it, I'll hit save.
Won't normally do that with things I'm just demoing,
but I'll hit save in this case.
I'm going to now drag this blueprint into my scene
because I won't be able to have remote control access to it
unless it's in my scene.
So I'm going to drag it right here.
That's going to ask me to say,
hey, do you want to check this out?
We'll say fine, whatever.
And we'll delete these later.
So we don't need to keep them.
So I drunk this into my scene.
This is all ready to go.
And you'll notice over here on the right,
there's a tint amount and a new color
with the dots that we have for our remote control preset,
because my remote control preset currently is open.
So I can go to my remote control preset
and now expose these.
And let me show you that briefly.
And then from there,
we're going to go to the wall and play with these,
but I'm going to show you briefly
that the control that we have.
So let me go to my remote control preset for a moment.
We'll open up our sample.
We'll expose the new tint amounts
and we'll expose the new tint color.
You'll see them open and show up.
Awesome.
And now if we want to, we'll go to the web app.
I will pull my conductor over.
I'll keep it in screen here.
We're going to go to design.
We're going to build our UI.
I'm going to go to my properties here
and let's actually just do some widgets here.
So we'll keep this fast.
We'll make this a little bit faster.
Oh, you've already seen the customization.
So we're just going to pull these in.
So there's the tint amounts.
With it selected, we can change that to like a dial
and we have color.
I can pull color in here.
We'll actually put it below.
There's a color wheel.
Let me move this over for a second
and open up that color wheel.
So now I can go in here and change my tint amounts
and I can change the color if I need to.
So we go a little bit lower, a little bit higher,
a little bit strong there
so we can make that a little bit there, tweak that out.
You can also reset it to default.
Okay.
And then we can mess with our color a little bit.
Excuse me.
But we also want to make sure we mess with our value here
so now we can mess with color and value.
So if there is a bit of a refresh issue,
just give it some time to be able to go
and do what you need it to do.
There you go.
Little bit of color change there.
Bump up the value a little bit.
There you go.
You can see some annoying gross green rocks
that you never want to touch with your bare skin.
And that's about it with this one.
So in the next video,
I'm gonna show you how to work with LevelSnapshot
and at the very end of our course,
I'll show you all of this stuff together
and us being able to have remote control.